[Music]
let's move on to a developing story in
Britain which is having a potential
knock-on effect for airline passengers
right around the world flights to and
from the United Kingdom are being
disrupted because of technical problems
with air traffic control and that is
restricting the flow of Aircraft
engineers are searching for a solution
that's across to Unique Barker who's
standing by for us at London City
airport so Neva just tell us the latest
what's what's happening
well the latest is the National Air
Traffic Service which is based down in
Hampshire Southwest of London are
continuing to say that they're having
major technical issues with the entire
system that's responsible for monitoring
and safeguarding the arrival and
departure of aircrafts to and from the
United Kingdom as well as domestic
flights as well as you say they've got
technical teams on the ground trying to
work out exactly what's happened and the
hope of restoring all of this very very
quickly indeed but most importantly they
don't know how it happened and they
don't know how long it's going to take
to repair if it takes minutes or
possibly even hours even longer than
that the likelihood is that it will have
a massive knock-on effect on the smooth
flow of air traffic to and from the
country but also much further afield
given the tight margins that operate at
major airports like Heathrow for
instance where aircraft arrive and land
something like every 90 seconds so the
air traffic service is basically having
to slow everything down reduce the
number of aircraft coming into the
country based easily going from a
digital system to an analog system and
that of course could have massive
implications for travel not only here in
the UK but internationally as well given
how important UK airports are are in the
whole Global Transport infrastructure
yeah a huge amount of traffic coming
into and through the UK which makes you
wonder about safety is there an issue
there
yeah of course I mean safety is a big
concern We Gather from Nats the National
Aviation Transport service that safety
isn't a big concern there are other
means and ways of for instance spacing
aircraft in the air the main issue
though is how this will all affect the
the pacing and the speed of aircraft
arriving in and traveling out of the
country here at City airport it's been
very very quiet since we've been here I
haven't seen a single plane takeoff and
land I've just had a quick look at the
departure board which makes a grim
reading particularly if you're hoping to
fly out of the country later on today a
flight to Amsterdam for instance it's
meant to leave at about an hour and a
half's Time expect 11 hour delay for
them similar story for even a flight to
Edinburgh so a flight in within the
United Kingdom meant to leave at 10 to 4
UK time again we're looking at a 12-hour
delay for people just going up the road
so I can imagine
all sorts of plans are going to be made
to find alternative means of Transport
by Road or by train and I can imagine
that an awful lot of people are already
starting to table emails to their bosses
this is of course a bank holiday weekend
uh people are hoping to return to work
on Tuesday a lot of people are
undoubtedly going to be concerned
whether that might even be possible
yeah grab those bus timetables quickly
all right Dave appreciate that thanks
very much indeed